- I wrangled 20 fourth-graders
at a bowling alley for two hours.
I can literally do anything.
You really find out who your friends are
when you declare a national emergency.
It's true.
It's the lesson that Donald Trump
is learning right about now.
Trump, you'll remember,
maybe you won't remember,
but you will now,
declared a national emergency
on the United States' southern
border on February 15th,
and said Trump of his
emergency declaration, quote--
- It's been signed many times before.
It's been signed by other presidents.
From 1977 or so, it gave
the presidents the power.
There's rarely been a problem.
They sign it, nobody cares.
I guess they weren't very exciting.
- (laughing) And Trump is sort of right.
Presidents have been
declaring national emergencies
since there, well, since
there have been presidents.
Franklin Delano Roosevelt
declared a national emergency in 1933
that allowed him to close
all the banks in the country
on a single day to avoid
them going bankrupt
in the heart of the Great Depression.
Harry Truman declared a
national emergency in 1950
to deal with the conflict in Korea.
And in 1970, Richard Nixon
declared an emergency
in the face of a postal strike,
which allowed him to
assign National Guardsmen
to deliver the mail, which
is an underrated story
that I would like to read a book about.
By the mid-1970s,
there was all sorts of
confusion and controversy
over when a president could
declare a national emergency
and what special powers
doing so gave to him.
Enter Congress.
Sometimes fixes problems, I
guess, way back in the past.
This time, they pass the
National Emergencies Act in 1976
to essential codify what a
president can and should do
in the face of an urgent
crisis in which they need
all of the tools of the federal government
at their disposal.
So, since 1976, presidents have used
the national emergency
declaration relatively sparingly.
Jimmy Carter only issued
one national emergency.
He did it to deal with Americans
that were being kept hostage in Iran.
Now, his successor, Ronald Reagan,
declared six national emergencies.
George Herbert Walker Bush, only four.
Bill Clinton holds the record
with 17 national emergency declarations
during his eight years in the White House.
George W. Bush, Barack Obama
each racked up about 12
emergency declarations each.
Now, the vast majority of all of these
national emergency declarations
were in service of
putting sanctions in place
against bad actors across the world,
whether that was Lebanon, Syria,
the Congo, or a whole
bunch of other places.
And the one thing
all of those national
emergencies had in common
was that they had broad
bipartisan support in Congress.
Now, whether they were in
response to some urgent need
or were part of a
broader pressure campaign
being brought to bear against a country,
these measures rarely even
drew the attention of Congress
or much if any news coverage.
But Trump's decision to
declare a state of emergency
on the Southern border is
then rightly understood
as the major exception to that rule.
It came after months of back-and-forth
with congressional Democrats
over how much money, if
any, they would approve
so that Trump could build his wall
on the country's southern border.
Now, when talks between
the two sides broke down,
we got a 35-day-long government shutdown,
the longest in American history.
But even when the government reopened,
there was no border wall
funding deal to be had.
So, rather than shut down
the government again,
Trump decided to declare
a national emergency,
which allows him to take money
Congress has already
approved for other purposes
and direct it to his wall
and its first-phase
$5-billion, billion, price tag.
Now, Congress, as you might
guess, didn't love that idea,
since deciding how the federal
government spends its money
is the legislature's business.
It's right here, there's
a Constitution back there,
but it's in there, trust me.
So, the Democratic House majority
introduced a resolution to reverse
the national emergency declaration.
- Well, we are not going
to give any president,
Democratic or Republican, a blank check
to shred the Constitution
of the United States.
We would be delinquent in our
duties as members of Congress
if we did not overturn what
the president is proposing.
That speech worked because the
resolution passed the House
with 245 votes, including 13 Republicans
who sided with their
Democratic colleagues.
And that was when things
got really interesting.
See, because this is what's
called a privileged resolution,
it means that the Senate
can't just ignore it.
Why?
Don't ask why.
The rules of Congress
are harder to understand
than Rob Kardashian's fame.
Actually, probably not that
hard, but still difficult.
Which puts Senator Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell
in a major pickle, and yes
that is a technical term.
Because if 51 senators
vote for the resolution,
then it goes to President
Donald Trump's desk,
and that appears to be exactly
what is going to happen.
Democrats hold 47 seats in the Senate.
All of them are expected
to vote for the resolution,
so that's 47.
And over the past few weeks, a quartet,
47 plus four equals 51,
of Republican senators,
Rand Paul, Lisa Murkowski,
Susan Collins, and Thom Tillis,
have said they will vote
for the resolution too.
And it honestly seems likely
more Republicans will follow that lead,
citing concerns that if Trump can declare
a national emergency
to get his wall built,
then Democratic presidents
could do the same to,
say, pay for a plan to,
I don't know, eliminate climate change.
So, in early-March, McConnell
sounded basically resigned
to losing this resolution vote.
- What is clear in the Senate
is there will be enough votes
to pass the resolution of disapproval,
which will then be
vetoed by the president,
and then, in all likelihood,
the veto will be upheld in the House.
- And he's right,
and that's the strange
thing about all of this.
If, and, really, if
I'm being honest, when,
the Senate passes the resolution
to end the national emergency,
Trump has already said he will veto it.
And it would be some history.
It would be the first veto
of Trump's presidency.
So, Trump vetoes it.
Then Congress would need two-thirds votes
in the House and the Senate
to overturn that presidential veto,
and that is just not happening.
The votes just aren't there.
They're not even really close to there.
So, Trump will get the money for his wall.
But Congress will have
made clear in the process
that they don't like it
and they think it opens Pandora's box
for every future president,
and they will be exactly 100% correct.
And that is the Po!nt.
We make new Po!nt episodes
every Tuesday and Thursday.
Make sure to check them all out.